si a lo largo del día de hoy rusia y
ucrania se acordaron para la abertura de
unos seis corredores humanitarios para
permitir la evacuación de los civiles de
las zonas más afectadas por los combates
finalmente según el gobierno ucraniano
sólo pocos de estos corredores
funcionaron y además lo hicieron de una
forma intermitente es decir sólo por
pocas horas nosotros estuvimos en la
estación del bid en el oeste del país y
efectivamente vimos a la llegada de
alguno de estos evacuados entre ellos un
grupo de estudiantes africanos de un
programa de intercambio procedían de la
localidad de schumi en el este del país
una localidad que ha sufrido intensos
bombardeos en los últimos días y todo
esto ocurre mientras quien sigue
acusando a moscú de seguir lanzando
bombas sobre sus convoys humanitarios y
también de haber atacado a un hospital
el hospital infantil de mariupol una
localidad en la que precisamente en los
pasados días se intentó en más de una
ocasión a proceder hacia una evacuación
unos intentos
y fracasaron una y otra vez